okay hi everyone I'm Alex chin it's a
pleasure to be here at NDC Oslo
apparently Snoop Dogg has also performed
at this theater so I'm walking among the
greats also I quit smoking cigarettes
yesterday so I'm feeling a little funny
so I apologize if I'm not super on top
of my game in this talk I mentioned
sexual harassment sexism racism
depression and addiction so feel free to
skip it if that's what you need to do
I'm about to get very real and honest
with everyone I hope that's okay I'm
gonna tell you the story of how shaving
my head made me a better programmer sort
of not really and all the lessons I've
learned along the way and then since
then I'm from Paris I was born and
raised there baurel any French people no
okay
I moved to the US to go to college and
that's where I learned to code I wanted
to be an astronaut so I joined the
engineering program at my school and one
of the requirements for the program was
to take intro to programming in Python
so I did and I fell in love with it
immediately it was like nothing I'd ever
experienced I felt like I could be
creative and analytical all at once I
felt like I had finally found a form of
art with which I could express myself so
I started programming and I decided to
major in computer science and that was a
very easy decision but staying in
computer science was not so easy and it
wasn't because learning to code is hard
which it is it's a lot of dealing with
your computer telling you you failed
over and over again but that wasn't the
hard part the hard part was overcoming
other people's perceptions and my own
perceptions about my abilities as a
programmer at the time I was one of
maybe five women in my computer science
classes there were some classes where I
was the only woman and there were very
very few people in my classes who hadn't
been coding since they were 10 years old
and even though I did well in all my
classes no one wanted to work with me or
talk to me it was very lonely it felt
like I was hyper visible and invisible
at the same time
and this was before all of the recent
scandals came out before the me2
movement before people started talking
about text lack of diversity before
there was really a shared language
around it so it was my first year in
college and computer science really
didn't seem like the place for me even
though I loved it people didn't really
believe I was a programmer they would
say to me prove it
do you know what the command line is
which is a ridiculous question but it
wasn't just the students one of my male
friends told me that our computer
science professor said this to him so
when are you gonna Alex
so my peers didn't see me as a
programmer and my professors didn't
either but it wasn't just them I didn't
believe in myself until my last year of
college when people would ask me if I
was a programmer I would say well not
really but I'm trying to become one
which is silly because the act of
programming is what makes you a
programmer but I'm really stubborn so I
decided I was going to be a good
programmer in a way that would be
unquestionable to the world so I joined
my school's competitive programming team
any other competitive programming nerds
out there yes okay and became a leader
for our schools Computer Club and took
all the hardest computer science classes
and won a bunch of hackathons and I
finally became accepted by my peers and
it's ridiculous that for other people
all they had to do was show up and look
nerdy and I had to do all this work but
I made it so it didn't seem to matter
then I graduated with a degree in
computer science in 2013 and I started
my career as a software engineer in New
York this photo was taken in front of
the McDonald's by Yankee Stadium because
that's where we had our graduation
ceremony and though I had experienced
some discrimination in school for being
a woman in the computer science
department I was not prepared for what
was about to happen in the tech world
and some of it was small stuff like
microaggressions like people asking me
over and over if I was sure I was a
programmer but there was also some
scarier more serious more traumatic
incidents like what we've seen has
happened at uber other companies in the
news and I'm gonna tell you about some
of these incidents and I used to give a
version of this talk where I didn't
mention these incidents because I was
speaking to a lot of young woman and I
didn't want to discourage anyone from
entering the tech field but now I think
it's important
share these I found a draft of a blog
post that I wrote after these incidents
happened when I was 22 years old and I
never published it I'm gonna read the
first few sentences of that blog post
now I didn't want to have to write this
I didn't want my first blog post to be
about this I wanted it to be about
something technical like browser
compatibility or accessibility or
anything else but I can no longer keep
silent and it's not because I can't bear
to hold this in but rather because you
all need to hear this I used to be one
of those women who believed that all
that mattered was my code I didn't want
to identify as female developer I just
wanted to be a developer and he goes on
I never published this blog post because
I was too afraid at the time but I'll
share these stories today five stories
that made me want to quit programming
and my first software engineering
internship I was the only woman on the
engineering team and a few weeks into
the job the QA lead asked me to get
coffee I was new and he was nice and so
I said yes as we were getting coffee he
started asking me personal questions
like where do you live what trains do
you take to work do you have a boyfriend
does he get jealous do you dress sexy
for him
do you wear lingerie for him and so and
so forth it made me very uncomfortable I
didn't know what to do or say so I just
finished my coffee as quickly as
possible and headed back to the office
after that I locked myself in the
women's bathroom and cried all afternoon
he kept trying to spend time with me
after that day but I was very nervous
around him and I really didn't like
having to work closely with him every
day I was too scared to tell anyone
because I was just an intern but on my
last day I got the courage to tell the
CTO what had happened he was very
surprised and saddened and you know he
told me but he's such a nice guy and he
assured me that he would make sure this
didn't happen again I later found out
that he continued to harass and actually
stalk women at that company but you know
he was a really nice guy in a high
performer after that experience I mostly
wore jeans and t-shirts to work and I
stopped wearing makeup or perfume
because I was afraid of getting that
kind of attention again after that I got
another job as a front-end engineer that
team was great and even though I was the
only woman on the team I felt safe and
supported and I was doing a great job we
were part of a portfolio of companies so
I got to attend a lot of tech events and
conference
is the job was awesome but what happened
at those events was not awesome
soon after I joined our team was invited
to a networking event organized by our
venture capital firm it was a nice
evening with an open bar and after a few
drinks I started talking to another
software engineer and at one point
during our conversation he tried to kiss
me and I had to physically push him away
after that happened I was pretty upset
but I tried to make the most out of the
event so I started talking to someone
else and after a while he also tried to
kiss me so I had to physically push
someone else away and at this point I
was furious so I yelled at him that this
wasn't okay and he told me I shouldn't
be so stuck-up and I took it as my cue
to leave the event and after that I was
very nervous at events where alcohol was
being served a couple months later our
engineering team went to San Francisco
for a programming conference one of our
investors was based in San Francisco and
he invited me to meet with him to talk
about my work and my career and the
company he said I had a lot of promise
and I thought this was a really good
opportunity for my career you know he
was a successful investor we met for
dinner and I quickly realized this was
not about work this was a date I tried
to steer the conversation towards work
ask him questions about the company
investing taking notes on my phone
trying to send every possible sign that
this wasn't a romantic situation without
offending him but he wasn't getting the
hint or maybe he was choosing not to
after dinner he asked me to come home
with him for champagne and he really
insisted it was very hard for me to say
no given that he was one of our
investors but I successfully left and
after that I was a lot less friendly
with the men that I met through work a
couple months after that I went to a
programming conference in Mexico it was
a very fun conference everyone lived in
little cabins by the beach you shared a
cabin with a few other people there was
a lot of drinking at this conference
one night one of the conference speakers
who was staying in my cabin let himself
into my room very drunk
I was asleep he woke me up and tried to
convince me to let him sleep in my bed
with him saying he didn't want to sleep
alone I was really scared but I
eventually got him out of my room the
next day I told the conference
organizers what happened and so they
sent out a reminder about the code of
conduct I spent the rest of the
conference locked in my room angry
crying not wanting to run into him
after that my engineering team always
sent a male chaperone with me to tech
conferences a few months after that our
company was growing so we hired a new VP
of engineering he'd never worked with a
woman on his team before and he was my
new boss and he would say things that
were really hard for me to hear he would
make jokes about how women existed only
to serve men he would make comments
about my appearance telling me he didn't
like the way I dressed or how I did my
hair one time I was wearing all black
and he told me I looked like a mustard
sandwich
which is I think because I'm Asian and
my skin is yellow I'm not sure when our
CEO disciplined him for his behavior
towards me he apologized to me and then
he said that women in tech like the
attention which was not the case for me
he also said he wished we had more women
on the team but that would mean he would
have to liar lower the hiring bar which
felt like serious insult and is also
very untrue and although I was one of
the first engineers to join the team and
my code was all over the codebase he
started pushing me on to smaller and
smaller projects giving me grunt work at
one point I was asked to stop speaking
during product meetings because I
intimidated the product lead who was
also a man and became impossible for me
to work there and I ended up having to
quit it was just too hostile a work
environment for me but is it really
quitting if you are pushed out so after
all these incidents of harassment
nowhere failsafe not my job not the tech
world not even code people were leaving
sexist comments on my pour requests on
open source projects a real comment that
I got and all of this happened by age 22
I was one year into my career and I was
not fine I became very depressed I even
tried to write a blog post about it but
I never published it I felt like why do
I love programming if programming
doesn't love me back and I was just
trying to do my job do what I love just
trying to write code and it was becoming
impossible for me to do that it was
actually making me depressed and it felt
like maybe this should be the end of my
career and I seriously considered
quitting programming but like I said
before I'm really stubborn so again I
tried to find a solution I sought out my
friends for advice and I realized I only
had male programmer friends
so I decided to meet as many women
engineers as possible I got friends to
introduce me to the women that they
worked with and I went on blind coffee
dates with a bunch of ladies and I was
looking for advice and looking to build
a support network and I asked them what
do i do how do I survive in this field I
got a lot of different advice one woman
who had been a professional programmer
for over 10 years told me that when she
cut her hair short she stopped getting
sexually harassed at tech events so I
kind of tossed that to the side
this one male friend told me why don't
you become a badass programmer like
these famous programmers that we know
become known for your expertise and then
people will have to take you seriously
they'll have to treat you with respect
basically telling me to lean in and I
thought okay I'll try that so I started
giving talks at meetups about things I'm
very passionate about the JavaScript
programming language web accessibility
and so forth and it went really well and
for some reason I was on the front page
of TechCrunch for a day that was a long
time ago when we still read tech runs
remember that I even got invited to
speak at a big programming conference
kind of like this one where people were
flying from around the country to attend
they paid hundreds of dollars for a
ticket I shared this stage with people I
really respected people who build the
tools that I used every day and I was
certainly the youngest person on stage I
was 23 and I was talking about something
I cared about accessibility on the web
so I was really excited I felt
accomplished I was badass I gave my talk
and it went really well but then the
first thing I got asked afterwards was a
gentleman in the audience asked me how
do I talk to women at bars and I
couldn't believe it after all the work
that I did to get there even in the
moment when my expertise was undeniable
I was literally on stage at a conference
that he paid money to attend teaching
him things even then I wasn't seen as a
programmer so I learned that being a
badass doesn't help after all this work
after leaning all the way in I wasn't
seen as a developer not even a female
developer just female and at this point
I was really angry I was so sick of
being treated this way because of my
gender and my appearance but I'm a
hacker so I decided to hack my
appearance I shaved my head just kidding
that's Natalie Portman I shaved my head
and the weirdest thing happened suddenly
overnight I was a good programmer I
stopped getting sexually harassed at
conferences people listened to me and
respected me I stopped being this mix of
hyper sexualized and under skilled
programmer and I tried to think about it
scientifically like is there something
in hair that makes me worse at
programming maybe my hair was weighing
me down like dragging my programming
skills down maybe this is an
aerodynamics problem like how swimmers
and cyclists shave their legs you know
but that's not right because this guy's
a really good programmer that's Richard
Stallman and these guys are really good
programmers too
they're Ken Thompson and Dennis Ritchie
the co-creators of UNIX and this guy's a
really good programmer too just kidding
that cereal from the movie hackers which
is a great film I hope you all watch it
so it had nothing to do with my hair but
now all of a sudden I was seen as a good
programmer what had changed then if not
my actual skills which definitely hadn't
leveled up overnight it was the way I
was being perceived by my peers I was no
longer this hyper feminine lady who
didn't belong and people even mistook me
and my boyfriend at the time for a gay
couple and so I didn't present us
feminine anymore and so it was
acceptable for me to be a programmer and
even a good one and this was a
mind-blowing discovery for me because
even though I knew that I was a good
programmer in my heart and I knew that
sexism was a thing now I really
understood it and had proof of it on a
personal level so I realized the tech
industry is not a meritocracy unlike I
initially thought
unlike many people had told me this
industry doesn't allow capable
passionate people like me to succeed
regardless of their skills it
systematically pushes out women and
gender non-conforming people people of
color people with disabilities etc and I
thought about the advice that people had
given me which was all about changing
myself
they said cut your hair become a badass
be more of a learn to ignore it
and I thought no it's not me who has to
change it's the tech industry that has
to change so I was 23 and I decided that
as long as I'm in this field I will work
to fix it to make it more diverse more
inclusive
better for all humans so I started my
quest to teach underrepresented and
vulnerable populations to code so that
we can change the face of technology
create pathways for economic mobility
for communities that have been left out
of tech and to empower more of us to
build the solutions to the problems that
affect us instead of our fate being in
the hands of others I started telling
this story and advocating for diversity
and inclusion at tech conferences and I
became a teacher in an advocate for
underrepresented people I built tech
education programs for people of color
people without college degrees
immigrants women and my students have
gone on to do incredible things some of
my Cristo Rey high students built an app
that teaches young adults about
affordable makeup and makeup styles for
all skin tones with the goal of
challenging white supremacists beauty
standards they went on to win multiple
hackathons and even demoed their app at
the emoji con conference one of the
students candy started college at
Stanford last year and his studying
computer science there I was the
curriculum director at Coalition for
Queens a free programming school for
adults from low-income and
underrepresented backgrounds where I
helped launch the program 50% of the
class was women 50% were immigrants 50%
had no college degree 50% were black and
Latin X and the average income of the
class when it started was about $20,000
a year so below the federal poverty line
in the United States and graduates went
on to work at the New York Times Spotify
BuzzFeed vice as professional software
engineers and they're making you know in
six figures now one of the projects that
came from this class was an Android app
called blazing an online community of
women children people of color and LGBTQ
folks that aims to combat street
harassment and madelyn one of the
students from the class joined Pinterest
and started technology casts a group for
Latinas in tech and has become an icon
an advocate for diversity in tech I've
mentored young girls in the worldwide
Technovation competition for that
competition two of my high school
students built an app that aims to
reduce reduce produce waste by
connecting farms to restaurants so that
farms can sell their ugly produce which
would otherwise be wasted this is a big
problem food waste in the United States
it's an iOS app called grow green Rachel
on the left is now studying computer
science at Yale University and Priya on
the right just graduated high school and
continuing to develop the app she was
named one of cranes 20 under 20 last
year and she recently spoke at the
global food Innovation Summit in Milan I
teach people to code as an ethical
practice this is a photo of some of my
students we're all wearing t-shirts that
have the binary representation of the
words with great power comes great
responsibility and after all this
teaching I've learned three very
important lessons about code
you shouldn't have to compromise on any
aspect of your identity to do what you
love some people have taken the wrong
message from this talk which is that you
should shave your head to be a coder
know since shaving my head I've had many
different hairstyles I wear it's short
now because that's how I feel you should
be able to just be you no matter who
that is and write code safely to
excellence in code can come from anyone
anyone can achieve excellence if they're
given support a safe space to learn and
if you trust that they can succeed I
truly believe this I've taught people
from age 12 to 63 from all socioeconomic
backgrounds races countries immigration
status gender and gender identity and
this is the truth and these projects
that my students have built they're
important they're game changers so we
need technologists from diverse
backgrounds if we have any hope for a
brighter future and it's because of
these beliefs that I started my latest
project in 2016 I read the book the new
Jim Crow by Michelle Alexander in which
I learned about how black and brown
populations are disproportionately and
unfairly criminalized and murdered in
the United States and how the system of
mass incarceration is truly the latest
iteration of slavery I wanted to learn
from people who had experience with the
criminal justice system so I started
teaching people who had been to prison
how to code and that's how the code
cooperative started now over two years
two years later we've become a community
of people who learn use and build
technology to create life-changing
opportunities for individuals and
communities that have been impacted by
incarceration we work for the liberation
of all beings we imagine and commit to
building a world where our collective
humanity is reflected in our technology
society and policy and we do this not
just for the
operation of people who have been to
prison but for our own liberation and
sense of justice because no one is free
until we are all free and then last year
I finally got the courage to call out
the men who had sexually harassed me at
docker con in San Francisco and at some
other conferences and the talk made its
way around Twitter it was a beautiful
moment of justice and I felt like I was
living my best life
I got everything I'd worked so hard for
I went from hello world freshman year of
college to almost quitting the tech
industry out of fear for my sanity and
safety to making a place for myself
within it where I was thriving and
unafraid I proved to the world I was
excellent I was fighting for the change
I wanted to see in the world and I was
doing work I really believed in with
people I cared about there were a lot of
labels I would use to describe myself at
this point founder director of
Technology international public speaker
social justice warrior badass workaholic
party girl
coding icon actually I would never call
myself an icon someone else did bless
their heart so it looked like I was
doing great on the surface but something
was catching up with me some you
don't show on Instagram chronic trauma
from repeated sexual discrimination and
harassment burnout divorce rage quitting
job after job losing work visas and a
green card self-medicating through the
fear and pain with alcohol and other
substances and depression and suicidal
thoughts in my fight to be excellent to
be accepted and to advocate for others
like me and ultimately get revenge I had
lost a lot all these years of trying to
be the best to be bold to be perfect had
come at the cost of something I couldn't
afford to pay anymore my wholeness and
freedom and I couldn't keep doing it so
I did what people do after they get
divorced I took a sabbatical this is a
more accurate reference any Bojack fans
cool
I decided to take a break from
everything and try to heal
I started removing all of my
distractions and coping mechanisms I
quit working social media dating and I
got sober I stopped numbing myself and
screening the world and I was forced to
sit with myself and with my feelings for
the very first time and to reckon with
the truth that I was not okay
that I had been harming myself for a
long time and I hadn't been able to stop
until I hit bottom but I was on a new
quest now a quest to become whole and
free I learned to stop engaging in
addictive harmful behaviors one day at a
time
under those behaviors were some deep
wounds that were created when I was just
a child wounds that I didn't even know I
had until then when I was very young I
learned that I was only worthy of love
if I was perfect and I realized that so
much of what I was doing since then was
in the pursuit of validation I wanted
the world to tell me I was worthy
because I didn't believe it myself and
because this was the story I had told
myself my whole life it would take
serious work to unlearn it
I learned to meditate and to practice
mindfulness so that would be able to
change my thoughts I started going to
meetings with other people who are going
through the same journey trying to stay
sober and I shared with them all my
challenges my fears and my shame and I
listened to them share theirs and after
a while of doing this every day and
saying things out loud I didn't even
believe and crying more tears and I
thought were possible to hold in one
body things started to move within me I
truly hacked my brain I learned that
feelings are temporary thoughts are not
truths beliefs aren't truths and I can
change my thoughts my beliefs and my
behaviors using these tools I've learned
to stop causing harm to myself and
others I stopped drinking alcohol and
doing drugs
I stopped reaching outside of myself for
validation from work success or other
people
I learned to practice honesty and
authenticity instead of projecting to
the world what I think will get me what
I want which is sometimes just as simple
as being seen being accepted and
belonging I learned to let go of my
personas one at a time and I learned
that I'm enough just as I am and I
started to make amends to the people
that I had harmed friends family members
co-workers lovers
and through this process I'm learning
that I'm not the harms that I've done
and what it means to be accountable to
my actions and to work hard to make
things right when I've done someone
wrong I learned what it's like to show
up and sit in the discomfort and the
pain to try to heal relationships
instead of just walking away I've
learned to look someone in the eyes and
say I'm sorry for hurting you how can I
make it up to you and I commit to doing
things differently and this has been
really hard and I wouldn't have been
able to get through it without the
support of people who don't judge me and
who hold me accountable to my values
over the past few months I've sat in a
lot of different rooms and listened to
people share stories about where they
are from and what matters to them
through hearing all these stories I've
come to realize a deep truth that I
relearn every day that we are all the
same I've listened to people who didn't
look like me people I never thought I
would relate to and I've heard myself in
their stories even though we have
different wounds different lived
experiences different circumstances we
all have pain and we all want the same
things to be safe to be seen and to be
loved and I saw the power of stories
through telling them we heal ourselves
and others through hearing them we
remember the truth that we are all one
and that we are all connected
traditional African society uses the
term Ubuntu to express the idea that
each of us is fundamentally a part of
the whole it translates to I am because
we are and this truth is why I'm here
today
within the past few years many people
have come forward with their own stories
of harassment and discrimination in tech
we have been shocked by some of the
stories we have heard or read including
my own so we have poured billions of
dollars into data collection new hiring
practices unconscious bias trainings
educational programs for people from
underrepresented backgrounds and other
diversity and inclusion initiatives and
where are we now we continue to hear
about incidents of racial and sexual
discrimination violence instead are
harming people and communities we are
not hiring more black and brown people
as is shown by Google's latest diversity
and tech report some of us are even
proudly advertising white only job
postings and we are learning that
leaders of our industry have been
covering up years and years of sexual
assaults needless to say
we are not in a better place or at least
not close to where we want to be in the
age of AI everywhere and mass
surveillance and predictive policing and
tech is a solution to everything and the
severe implications of all of this on
humanity the issue of our industry and
our society's homogenous and harmful
culture is more critical than ever we
here in these rooms are the deciders of
what happens to other people our
decisions have real impacts and that's
why we need more different people in
these rooms because the future is in the
margins our public shaming tactics and
half-hearted top-down policies have not
been working because we are not
addressing the root of the problem we
need to shift how we see each other in
our relationships we need to radically
transform ourselves in our communities
we keep asking how do we make the tech
industry more diverse but I've been
thinking about a new question recently
how do we heal how do we heal our
communities in our industry how do we
heal our internalized racism sexism
transphobia and all our other harmful
beliefs thoughts and behaviors how do we
heal the harms that were done to us and
the harms we have done to others how do
we heal our relationships and how do we
learn to be whole and free together it
was a little over a year ago that I gave
this talk where I called out the men who
had sexually harassed me and I was asked
to give the same one today but I
realized that I couldn't when I called
these men out I shared their full names
photo and where they worked
after years of staying silent I spoke up
and I was really scared but the response
was overwhelmingly supportive within
three hours to women messaged me to tell
me some of these men had harmed them - I
really felt like I'd done the right
thing I was a warrior fighting for
equality giving a voice to the voiceless
telling others who'd been victims of
discrimination and harassment
I can speak up so you can speak up - or
at the very least this is messed up and
you are not alone and hopefully
inspiring people to make a change in
their communities so that others don't
have to go through the same thing and I
know that some positive things have come
from me doing this but now I also see
how some harm has come from this when
these incidents happened I was so scared
and so angry I felt completely powerless
and the only way I knew how to regain my
power was to take power away from those
who had taken mine and that's why I
resorted to public shaming them I did it
in the name of truth and justice but I
also did it out of revenge but public
shaming is not the way that we heal as a
community and that's not the way that I
heal because when I harm others I harm
myself and hate cannot drive out hate
only love can do that when these
incidents of harassment happened early
on in my career it created a deep wound
in me I began to fear men in tech a
story was written in my mind that I will
continue to be hurt by people who look
like this but this doesn't have to be
the truth there are many stories and
beliefs I've learned throughout my life
they came from various places when I was
little I learned that I'm not worthy of
love unless I'm perfect unless I'm the
best at everything that's why I never
gave up in my pursuit for success and
greatness and software I couldn't give
up even if it was harming me when I
started coding I learned the story that
Tech is a meritocracy and if I'm good at
code then I will succeed
and if I don't succeed it must be that
I'm not a good coder from the media and
my teachers I learned that women and
minorities are just less interested in
coding and white and Asian men are
better at it but something happened that
made me unlearn that story and I learned
a new story that Tech is not a
meritocracy excellence in code can come
from anyone and we all deserve an
opportunity to be a part of this
community this industry and to co-create
the future we all deserve to be here to
be safe and to thrive no matter what
body we were born in we have all learned
stories we learn stories about what it
means to be a woman what it means to be
a man what gender is who is a criminal
and who is not deserving of being
treated like a human we didn't choose
these stories who we learned them from
our parents from our teachers from our
friends from the media and from society
but we can unlearn these stories and we
can choose to learn new ones the story
of who is a programmer was created in
the 1980s women invented computer
science and were the first programmers
in the 80s there was a big drop in women
programming that's when personal
computers started showing up personal
computers were basically toys so
companies decided to market them to men
and boys and this idea that computers
are for boys became the story we told
ourselves about computers it defined who
geeks were the image of the boy genius
programmer emerged and this led to where
we are now a place where the story is so
old and so strong that we can't tell
it's not the truth and we can't tell
where it came from and so we treat each
other like this but this is just a story
and now that we're aware of it we can
unlearn it but being aware isn't enough
changing our behaviors thoughts and
beliefs takes work the stories we've
learned about who belongs in our
industry and who gets to succeed are
like air we have been breathing in for a
very long time toxic poisonous air and
because these stories have been there
for so long it will take time to rewrite
them these are the most traveled neural
paths in our brains but we can travel
new ones what if instead of seeing our
internalized racism sexism etc shameful
flaws that we want to hide or ignore we
saw them as wounds we need to heal
stories to unlearn what if we were given
the support we needed to do this to
learn about these structures of
oppression and reflect on how they've
impacted our lives and those of the
people around us and share about it with
each other what if we were given the
space to practice mindfulness and self
compassion so that we could change our
thoughts the space to mess up and try
again to do better tomorrow what if we
were given the support we needed to do
the hard inner work it takes to unlearn
these harmful stories and write our own
stories what if we didn't live in fear
of being discovered but in mutual
support we could go to a group of people
who are going through the same journey
and be honest about our fears our
challenges in our shame these types of
circles exist
men's healing groups working to end
sexual violence white people against
white supremacy groups what if one harm
happened in our communities instead of
ignoring silencing shaming and exiling
we were accountable to each other we
shared the responsibility for our
collective well-being what if one harm
happened we saw it as a collective
failure in a collective opportunity and
centered the needs of the people
impacted as those who were harmed how do
you feel and what do you need
we make things right and then help those
who caused harm accountable for doing so
and then gave them what they need to
make a change and heal as well what if
we move from punitive to restorative
restorative justice practices which
we've learned from indigenous people are
being used more and more to respond to
interpersonal harm in the u.s. in
schools prisons and now in the workplace
what if we measured our success by the
strength and depth of our relationships
because we are all one and we all need
each other to survive what if we work
together to heal heal ourselves our
relationships our communities our
movements and worlds we could make
something beautiful happen normally
don't get a chance to actually interact
for a lot of our students traditional
job paths aren't necessarily an option
because of their history with the
criminal justice system what we do is
provide free technology education to for
Mo'Nique our serrated and justice
involved individuals as a pathway to
equity the technology and having access
to information and being able to use it
is really it's like the most powerful
currency allowing someone to tap into
their own creative energy
their own ideas and be able to sort of
like to magnify that just by learning
some basic things like HTML and CSS is
super important these concepts and the
language to describe is all about the
baggage treat I could see the world
differently that was like people that
have been affected by the justice system
are put at a big disadvantage in our
society they're discriminated against
because of their form of incarceration
these skills are essential to help
people get jobs to support themselves so
I think it's a way of leveling the
playing field
we pair each of our students with a
mentor who is a professional software
engineer that relationship between the
mentor and the mentee because it's
one-on-one you get to really sort of
tailor the interaction really towards
supporting the
as much as possible if it's just you
wanting to know basic knowledge of how
to browse web how to check an email it's
worth it if you want to go more in depth
and learn how to create a webpage if all
the tens on what you
this is the opportunity to be a future
if I really believe in myself I need
energy out here and you know
opportunities enough to love this place
the cool cooperative makes me feel
if you want to learn more about
computers if you want to learn to code
if you want to do good and you don't
really know how if you want to join a
community of like-minded people who care
about learning together and building
technology to make a better world join
us I imagine a world where we are no
longer harming each other where we all
have access to food shelter education
and love where the body we were born in
doesn't determine what opportunities we
have access to where we aren't
destroying our planet where there are no
prisons I truly believe we all want this
this world is within reach
we have everything we need to get there
we have all of the information we need
to create a change it isn't a matter of
facts it's a matter of longing of having
the will to imagine and implement
something else and we have to start
right now we have spent too long going
in the other direction and all we have
to do is to start with ourselves I truly
believe that you transform yourself to
transform the world I have been learning
a new story that I'm worthy no matter
what I do no matter what other people
say that you are not separate from me
and that when I heard others I hurt
myself and that my own liberation cannot
come at the cost of harming others this
world we imagine is within reach we can
get there but we can only make it happen
together now is the time to be brave and
to wage love thank you
[Applause]